information from South Wales police
shortly stay with us for that
now the nurse accused of murdering seven
babies and attempting to murder 10
others
thank you
foreign
providing an update on what happened in
Ely South Wales on Monday
um there was a brief statement from
police yesterday
about the deaths of two teenagers Kyrie
Sullivan and Harvey Evans the teens
killed in a bike crash in Ely their
deaths
sparked riots on the streets on
residential streets in the area the
force the police force last night
referred itself to the police Watchdog
the independent office for police
conduct has since agreed to
independently investigate the incident
this was after CCTV footage emerged of a
police van following the bike in the
minutes before the crash we have had
tributes from the families of the two
Cardiff teenagers today
saying they were best friends and went
everywhere together let's bring in Dan
Whitehead who is there in South Wales
for us at this news conference and so we
did hear from South Wales police last
night down what more detail are we
likely to get today what are they going
to be focusing on do you think
I think the two key updates which we've
had today so Jay and R of course that
the fact that the police Watchdog now
has said that they are independently uh
investigating the incidents in Ely on
Monday uh night that of course now is a
an active investigation it follows
um the release of that CCTV last night
showing what appeared to be a police van
chasing the bike just a few moments just
over three minutes before that fatal
Collision
um that will form a significant part
perhaps of the press conference and of
course in the last half an hour so we've
also had tributes from the family
members of Harvey Evans who have of
course 15 and Kyrie's Sullivan who
boasts both lost their lives Harvey's
family saying that their hearts are
truly broken by the sudden death of
Harvey our much-loved son grandson
brother nephew friend and boyfriend uh
the families as well in their statements
calling for calm in the a community and
to allow the police to carry out their
investigation of course that fatal crash
then triggered riots in Ely that went on
throughout the night on Monday night
around 150 people uh taking part in that
violence which saw fireworks and broken
Paving slabs being thrown at police a
number of offices injured in that
disturbance and there was certainly a
feeling of anger on that night and
certainly the next day towards police
and perhaps how the family members were
dealt with following that tragedy we
heard in a statement from David Ford
who's the director of the iopc the
police Watchdog in relation to that
independent investigation that's been
launched that of course follows South
Wales police referring itself to them he
said
that of course the iep's thoughts and
sympathies go out to the family but it's
important that they independently
investigate the circumstances leading up
to this tragic event they'd say they're
just Vision to investigate follows their
attendance to the police post incident
procedure and a review of information
specifically any interaction between
police and the boys seen in that CCTV
footage now today's Sky News is obtained
two new pieces of CCTV footage which
show the uh assumed Chase continuing a
few seconds later where we see those two
young boys on that electric bike
followed that by that police van the
questions of course surround just how
long uh if that is the case that chase
took place police have been Keen to
stress in their statement last night
that no police vehicles were on the road
in question where the fatal accident
occurred so that will fall part of the
IOP season of course South Wales
police's investigation as to whether or
not they had pulled away or stopped in
that Pursuit and how long exactly it
went on for I think we are now about to
hear from Rachel bacon the deputy chief
Constable so we'll listen in I think in
the next couple of minutes
to what she has to say and we are being
told she will take questions as well in
terms of on the ground of the crash site
today we've had family and friends
attend the crash site where there is now
understandably a large selection of
tributes and flowers and balloons being
laid and
that continues to grow what is a very
difficult time for the community we
understand on Friday night uh a vigil
and balloon release will take place and
of course first and foremost incredibly
difficult time uh for the families of
those loved ones let's listen now to
deputy chief Constable Rachel bacon
Chief Constable Rachel bacon of South
Wales police on Monday evening a serious
road traffic collision happened in
Snowden Road Ely which tragically
claimed the lives of Kyrie Sullivan and
Harvey Evans two friends who live in the
community of Ely our thoughts are with
the families and friends of kairis and
Harvey and everyone affected by this
terrible incident we can only begin to
imagine the grief they are experiencing
this at this time
their families continue to be supported
and updated by Family liaison officers
I am aware of concerns in the local
community regarding the timeline of
events which culminated in the Fatal
Collision including CCTV footage which
shows a police vehicle following a bike
in Frank Road
therefore I want to confirm the timeline
of events which took place as we know
them at this time
we would have liked to provided this
level of information yesterday but this
is a complex investigation and we had to
be sure of the facts before confirming
them
we have been busy obtaining witness
accounts analyzing tracking data from
police vehicles and studying CCTV and
this is what we know now
1759-40
CCTV shows the bike traveling towards
the police vehicle in Frank Road the
bike then turns around
1800 52 the bike is followed by the
police vehicle
which you have already seen on CCTV
images neither blue lights or Sirens
were in use
1801 18
police vehicle is at new Ely Church
roundabout and travels through Archer
Road
stanway Road and Howell Road
1802-31
police vehicle turns onto Grand Avenue
1802-18 to 1802 41 this is the
approximate time of the road traffic
collision on Snowden Road at the time of
the Collision the police vehicle is in
Grand Avenue half a mile away from
Snowden Road
1806-59 the police vehicle is on
cowbridge Road West when it receives
information about a road traffic
collision officers illuminate blue
lights and make their way to the
Collision scene
there was no police vehicle in Snowden
Road at the time of the collision and we
believe there were no other vehicles
involved in the incident
we have based this on witness accounts
tracking data and CCTV
we have made a mandatory referral to the
independent office for police conduct to
ensure the matter receives independent
scrutiny
we will provide them with all the
information we have and they will
undertake an independent investigation
I will now turn to the violence and
disorder which happened in Ely on Monday
night nothing can excuse this property
was damaged and people were scared in
their own homes
our Focus now is to fully cooperate with
the iopc investigation into the
circumstances of the collision and to
investigate the appalling scenes that
followed
we are appealing for Witnesses
information and footage from mobile
phones and social media
we have already recovered around 180
pieces of bodyworm video video footage
from police officers at the scene and
this number is expected to grow officers
are also going through hundreds of hours
of public CCTV and physios posted on
social media
anyone aware who has footage of Monday's
events can upload it to a link on our
website we are extremely grateful for
the support of the community so far and
urge anyone with any information to come
forward to us I will now take questions
what Chase was about why were you
following the two bodies on the bike and
what was the last point at which the
police were actively following it
listening to your time because there if
I got them correctly it seems to be just
a few seconds before the Fatal Collision
that of course contradicts what we
initially thought that there was no
police chase so what was the cause for
the Chase and at what point did you stop
chasing them I want to be as transparent
and open as I can with the communities
of Ely so that they understand what has
happened I've set out the timeline based
on the factual information that we have
but the iopc are conducting an
independent investigation regarding
whether any Pursuit has taken place so I
can't fully answer your question today
and for that I apologize
for so long well into Tuesday
situation yesterday morning was still
very unclear
I've explained to you the huge amount of
work that has had to be undertaken to
get to the point where we are I would
have wanted to speak to our community
sooner and I haven't been able to
because we haven't had that level of
information
find commissioner go out to the media
and say these were classrooms the
commissioner was very clear in his
interviews that situation was uncertain
but that there was no police car
following the e-bike at the time of the
Collision as you know Alan has a very
close relationship with the communities
of Ely and he wanted to give as much
information as he could as soon as
possible would you regret that initial
messaging from the from the police force
and the commission all I can tell you is
that we have done our best in the
circumstances we face with the
information we've had we've been an
honest and direct I'm here today to give
you the information I have now I've
still got hundreds of hours of
investigation that will need to take
place I know you're not going to get
every answer you want today but speaking
to the communities of Ely we are here to
protect you
we absolutely understand that it was a
terrible night we need to focus on
bringing those offenders to Justice the
BCC has just seen the footage in the
last half an hour but
time was coming from 1801 is from
stanway Road it shows two boys on their
bike cabinet from Archer and following
the police now this seems to contradict
your timeline because it seemed as
though the only reason they couldn't get
along into the room would crash happen
because there's four hours at the end
I've been really clear that I've given
you factual and accurate information to
this could you let me finish thank you
absolutely to the best of my knowledge
at this moment in time I have told you
that I have hundreds of hours of CCTV I
could have waited could have not come
here today to try and talk about what we
know and the timeline as we understand
it but I'm here today to talk to the
communities of Ely to let them know that
we absolutely understand their concerns
that we're listening to what you are
saying to us on their behalf about their
worries about the accuracy of what we
have said what I have told you is
accurate but there is other information
I've been really clear that we still
gone awful lot of CCTV to view and of
course that will be much now by the iopc
as they have taken independent
investigation and I'm sure that they
will keep you updated with their
progress
the process of events and the way the
timeline has been handled
says damage your liability when you say
and it's fair to say that this is not
tell people it's dead into people's week
we're absolutely passionate at
protecting the people of Ely we have a
dedicated neighborhood policing team we
want to reach out to them we want to
work with them it didn't go as any of us
would have wanted on the night of the
incident it is a tragic outcome that two
young men have died and we want to
understand why and the
situation that occurred afterwards in
terms of people's behavior is totally
unacceptable and I absolutely know as
you do that the people of Ely condemn
that
they don't want that to be happening in
their neighborhood and neither do we and
we will work tirelessly with them to
understand what we can do to support
them going forward
have they been questioned under caution
no they haven't okay
thank you
detective Deputy rather Chief Constable
Rachel bacon they're conducting that
news conference for South Wales of
police getting quite heated at the end
there as Jonas tried to ask questions
but Rachel bacon saying that she's
coming there in good faith to try and
provide some information to the
community of Ely who have suffered
unimaginably over the last couple of
days
um she said concerning the community
about the timeline of events that led to
the crash that killed the two teens from
Ely led to her coming out to give what
information she has at this time and she
spoke about the timeline that saw the
bike approach the police van the bike
that was carrying both teenagers it then
turned around and she also talked about
that CCTV footage which showed the
police van following the boys on the
bike around a minute later however the
crucial bit of information she gave
there was that at the time of the
Collision
that killed the two boys
the police vehicle scene on CCTV was
half a mile away it then got a call
that alerted the police officers inside
that van to attend the sea no police
vehicle was on Snowden road which was
the road that the Collision took place
on no police vehicle was on that road at
the time of the Collision no other
vehicle was involved in the Collision
that killed the two boys and she
referenced the independent investigation
that is now underway by the iopc she
said they're cooperating on the
circumstances surrounding the collision
and the events that led to the disorder
that followed that Collision she ended
by appealing for Witnesses and
information Sky's Dan Whitehead was in
the room and down such is the the level
of anxiety in the community and the Need
For answers that it got quite heated at
the end there but the families of Harvey
and Kyrie's today have put out
statements asking for peace and to let
the police get on with their business so
that they can get the answers the family
so desperately warm
yeah I mean obviously they will be
advised by Family liaison officers from
the police
um southwest police clearly under a lot
of pressure after uh the emergence of
this CCTV footage to give answers and to
give updates uh they mentioned there the
chief Council deputy chief Constable
that they're going through hundreds and
hundreds of hours of CCTV so on one hand
it was a relatively detailed chronology
down to the second of where that police
van was which has become the focus now
more so of course than the actual
writing which took place but exactly the
involvement of the police and these two
young boys it was interesting to note
that Rachel bacon didn't admit that
there was a Chase and wouldn't go into
the context of why it appeared that
police found was going after the two
boys whether or not that was based on on
intelligence any potential crime not
being drawn into those questions
and her remarks echoed what we heard
yesterday from police that there was no
police vehicle as you say on the road
Snowden Road when that fatal Collision
happened
um she talked about the the journey uh
going through Frank Road through new Ely
Church roundabout Archer Road stanway
Road Howell Road those are all roads
that are very close to the craft start
really within uh half a mile it's very
residential uh area and just where the
riots happen and just where the actual
crash happened is the end of a road a
dead end road with a lot of bollards and
a lot in the local community are saying
and we've spoken to why Witnesses who
believe that that bike stopped there
police weren't able to get through it's
a dead end and then about 200 meters
further on that is where the crash
happened this is obviously a complex
investigation as you said and it is
going to take time but Rachel bacon was
trying her best I think to try and
reassure the community which as you say
is frustrated and has been frustrated
clearly in the immediate aftermath of
what happened on Monday night with the
riots that took place into the early
hours but we have spoken to countless
people not only family members friends
who were frustrated with how police have
dealt with this no admission of of
regret they did interestingly say that
it didn't go the way that anyone would
have wanted to I think that was what
I've written here what Rachel bacon said
in terms of
obviously the situation on the night I
think she was referring to but also how
things were handled yesterday and a lot
of evidence came out yesterday uh which
changed the the series of events still a
lot of questions unanswered why were
they uh being followed by police
um interestingly as well something new
that they said that the the boys on the
bike were heading towards the van uh
first of all then turned around in an
apparently moving away from the police
and that is when that apparent Pursuit
uh happened so still a lot of questions
and South Wales police clearly still
under significant pressure they did take
questions there were plenty more who
wanted to ask them this of course comes
on top of now an active iopc
investigation so as is standard
procedure if there is or apparent police
involvements in something serious like
this there is then of course a referral
to the police Watchdog the iopc this
afternoon accepted that they believe
that they do need to carry out an
independent investigation itself away
from southwest police into exactly what
unfolded and what happened here on
Monday nights the iopc saying that they
will be examining any interaction
between the police and the boys after
that CCTV footage emerged were they on a
call out was it based on intelligence
intelligence or was it simply something
that happened in the street and of
course
um it's still not completely clear how
long that Pursuit happened and when did
it end before that fatal Collision
occurred which caused the deaths of
Harvey and curries we've had the
statements of course as well finally
from the two families today
uh Harvey's family uh saying that the
hearts are truly broken by the sudden
death of Harvey describing him as a
much-loved son grandson brother nephew
friend and boyfriend they say that he
lived life to the full
um and Kyrie's family saying that he was
a loving caring handsome young man a
loving son to Belinda and Craig and
little brother to Elia and uh Jordan let
me just go through the statement as well
because you did mention there
um that I think it was Harvey's family
here we go Harvey's family saying that
we ask for peace in the community and
request that people leave the
investigation to the police so we can
get the answers and we desperately need
to lay Harvey to rest as is often the
case in tragic situations like this
there are plenty of rumors and
falsehoods swirling around on social
media there is no doubt that that makes
things more difficult for the families
it makes things more difficult for the
police in terms of their investigation
um it of course helps to expose those
things like the CCTV because we've got
to revert back to tomorrow yesterday
morning's interview from the South Wales
police and crime commissioner who denied
there was any police chase and then of
course this footage emerged clearly
showing some form of involvement between
the police and the bike in Sky News has
obtained a couple of new bits of CCTV
from houses further down that video that
we had last night showing at those
events we now have a bit more chronology
in terms of which roads the police van
went down so for the families still big
questions it is clearly going to take a
significant amount of time for South
Wales police and the iopc to get to the
at the bottom of of what level
involvement the police had and whether
or not there was any relation to the
deaths of the two boys those are the big
questions which Harvey's family say they
desperately need in order to lay him to
rest okay Dan the top of this over
course there is incredibly upsetting
scenes for the family yeah indeed Dan
thank you very much so some more
information from South Wales police this
afternoon they've come out and given
some more detail on the timeline of
events that led to that fatal Collision
that killed the two teenage boys you see
on your screen there Harvey Evans on the
left kairis Evans on the right
um
deputy chief Constable Rachel bacon
saying concerning the community about
the timeline is what has led her to come
out today to give a bit more detail but
still a lot of questions unanswered
um
Rachel bacon the deputy chief Constable
did leave the press conference with
questions still being asked is a little
uh snippet of that
passionate of protecting the people of
Ely we have a dedicated neighborhood
policing team we want to reach out to
them we want to work with them it didn't
go as any of us would have wanted on the
night of the incident it is a tragic
outcome that two young men have died we
want to understand why and the
situation that occurred afterwards in
terms of people's behavior is totally
unacceptable and I absolutely know as
you do that the people of Ely condemn
that
they don't want that to be happening in
their neighborhood and neither do we and
we will work tirelessly with them to
understand what we can do to support
them going forward
so there you have it the police officers
are involved in the um well it hasn't
been called a Chase but they were
following that the bikes the boys were
on that have not been interviewed under
caution that was the last question uh
did deputy chief Constable Rachel bacon
answered um Dan
um just give us an idea of where this
goes now
uh well it's obviously a complex
investigation that was the words that
Rachel bacon used they talked about 180
pieces of body worn camera hundreds of
hours of CCTV it is clearly going uh to
take time as those investigations uh
continue not only into the fatalities of
those two young boys but also uh the
riots which took place throughout the
night which they have described as
totally unacceptable and I think
for the community and the families who
have called now for the police to be
able to get on with that investigation
the police will be hoping and police
sources have told me they were relieved
that there was no violence last night on
the second night that they can continue
that work in that investigation uh
without any violence in the community I
think the community itself perhaps a
focus on Friday to allow the family
members and friends to remember uh those
two people who died in that video
Dan Whitehead in bridgenda South Wales
for us thank you
coming up next here on Sky News it's the
NewsHour with